your your
your Bureau tonight's guests Weird Al
Yankovic
but first elephants we have a great show
for you today but wait a minute
oh it's what is it I said butterflies
but no butterflies not well of course
they let them outside they should be
free to enjoy a beautiful Icelandic day
well the unicorn wants butterflies make
it happen or you can go back to editing
Scandinavian porno videos yay Allie
flies Allie flies are the next step in
evolution like zebra coyotes and sports
the lineage of the songs goes on for
several eons in fact
the dinosaurs what you think the aleph
line was a cop-out gabba gabba you think
it's such a thing doesn't exist
oh well neither do unicorns silly yeah
guys they're not exactly I'll be back
but first we have to talk to our special
guest beard else games bitch wow it is
such a pleasure to be here isn't it
yeah I gotta tell you I'm a big big fan
I'm a colleague Wow yes yes that's very
avant-garde den just like your music
what I really adore well if you adore it
so much what have you never done a
parody of it well I kind of bow as a
parody already what yeah well you know I
take someone's there are four words and
then I make a backwards but you know
your songs are already backwards so I
mean that'd be kind of pointless women I
mean it's like if I take the song that's
backwards and make it forwards I just
have a normal song you know that's like
nothing that you - oh that is maybe it's
like the evolution of us off evolution
we're just talking about that oh yeah
you know the Darwin's Bicentennial is
coming up I know
oh so you're into the old Bicentennial
thing yes
I think everyone's bisexual to some
degree or other having to choose between
men and women is like having gestures
between ice cream and cake you'd be deaf
not to try both just once
Wow I mean wow do you write songs about
bisexuality oh yeah I don't think polka
covers that I did write a song called
Jurassic Park though which is kind of
about evolution sort of not really sure
a sick part sounds like jambalaya
actually no it doesn't but okay all
right jambalaya
yeah hi I'm John balaiah the talking
genie your wish is my command
York I wish for the whole world to feel
my music what I wish for the children of
the world to go on a mountaintop with a
radio and good batteries and sing a
joyous tune and save the world from
suffering succotash I'll tell you what
I'll give you a cookie
okay well let cookie do okay all right
there you go one cookie
it tastes like stir just in unicorn yes
that's probably the MSG hey your
celebrity spoof artist and accordion
fetishist we're doing in Quebec aren't
you that's right you did that go classic
uh UHF yeah did you like it No so what
are you up to
oh nothing much you got that right what
a genuinely unlikable person answered
beasts so tell us about your latest song
well um okay uh it's a it's a spoof of
meatloaf I take his song I do anything
for love and turn into a polka ballad
about a meatloaf who doesn't want to be
turned into a meat cake with potato
frosting potato
you
what was that we call him solanum
tuberosum destroyer of worlds
did you call him ship okay so um I take
a song about ship solanum tuberosum huh
the potato do you want to just hear the
song okay
Oh finally good and now I'm trying to
talk to my agent you don't begin to
think this is a low point in my career
shut up well hello Bjork why if it isn't
our producer mr. yurt grunts wood scooch
over Weird Al what is it mr. Kingsley
well Bjork it appears that the last of
our sponsors has pulled out and thus
Icelandic Public Television has also
pulled out this whatever this is has got
to go
no no I don't think you understand it's
all over you see the bottom has dropped
oh my god you kill them you tell them
that you saw a light for the precious
gift that was and you snuffed it out of
them why do not fear your can heal all
wounds
oh my god how did you do that
York's ways are strange it's a miracle
Oh Bjork thank you so much for saving my
life well there's nothing I could really
do about that
Oh oh my god you killed him you killed
him again oh well at least you can just
bring it back to life right No why not
cuz we haven't talked to our special
guests yet baloney sandwich
hello mr. baloney sandwich you know that
sandwich doesn't look very well he is a
cold you know what he needs
penicillin no oh I bet he's half
penicillin at this point he needs love
love what oh oh god oh oh my God why
would you do that I thought you loved
him sometimes we hurt the ones we love
oh I'm eatin Twinkie Wiener sandwiches
there were less gross than that I mean
this shows just too much for me it can I
go now of course not you haven't talked
to our guest yet the sandwich not the
sandwich
the chair oh right something sensible at
last what sorcery is this
weird al' meat Cheerilee knee toasty and
TVD say hello you guys they're not a
live they are low
are you hearing them now say hello oh oh
you're in for it now
let's say something quick we've lost
three guests that way well what do I do
I don't know I normally just braid
through the potato god I kept relying on
the tail maybe I can just make it up
oh no you can't do that she knows we're
now do you love cheer lean well I think
that is um oh please they'll kill me
I've come so far in this life but I
don't want to die in the frozen tundra
of Iceland because I can't carry on a
conversation with a snooty feud on
please please o merciful queen of the
crazies it's better this Boca loving
plies tear lien likes you she she does
she thinks you're cute and silly oh
that's a relief
unfortunately mr. Chester says you have
to die what
no I